Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
ford.
I'm sorry.
Wasam.
Captain
[Silence]
There's a a narration
which has been collected by many of the
scholars of hadith and it's in the
majority of the major books of hadith on
the authority ity of a companion by the
name of Abdman.
He said
the messenger of Allah sallall.aii Wasam
prohibited
meaning and prohibited us prohibited in
general
that a person peck the pecking of a
crow
or that a person
lay out
in the posture of an animal or a beast
a tiger or a lion.
Or that an individual
turn his head the turning of a fox.
or that a person fall
a camel does when it goes to sit
down or lay down.
Or that a person choose a place for
himself that he always is in
in the masid a camel chooses a
place
for itself in its pen or in its corral.
This narration
has a lot of prohibitions in it. These
prohibitions are all with regards to
salah. In salah,
he mentions
turning the head a fox.
He mentions pecking a crow.
He mentions
falling a camel does when it
goes to lay down. He mentions
choosing a place for yourself that you
always always pray in in the masid.
You're always in that same place just
a camel chooses a place in its pen
and it doesn't go anywhere else to find
its refuge and rest.
And he prohibited that a person lay
himself out a beast.
Now what do these things mean? These
things are all in what? In salah.
So let's start with the first one.
Turning the head a fox. What is
that? Who could who here is the that's
going to enlighten us with respect to
the meaning of this
turn in the head a fox? You know,
foxes are very
they are very paranoid creatures,
right? They're very smart. They're very
paranoid. They're always looking around
making sure that there's no predators.
What is this a prohibition of?
Somebody say something
that a person turn his head around
looking around in salah. But this is
actually in what? In when a person goes
to say
all right.
this this movement or that it's not all
the way.
This is prohibited and this will
invalidate a person's prayer if they do
not say it properly.
And
Ibn Mas and others of the companions
they said that when we would pray behind
the prophet sallall.aiam
when he would make aim
he would look as far as he could to his
right.
And we would be able to see the full
whiteness of his cheek when he would
make a salam. So he would make a salam.
If a person were behind, they would see
the full side of the cheek. What is
impermissible is half turns and that
they be quick and swift a fox.
This here
can potentially invalidate a person's
prayer because one of the pillars of
prayer is what? Salam. It's the final
pillar. And so if a person does not make
a salam correctly in the sense that they
say it completely
and the bare minimum issu
then the person's prayer may be invalid.
How about moving the head around when a
person is in any other position of
prayer
to look at something that's going on to
move the head and to see? If there's no
need to do this, no need for the prayer
or in general they're just looking
around.
Muslim the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
if there's no need for it. When he was
asked about turning the head
in prayer, he said it is a type of
stealing that a shan thieves from a
person's prayer, meaning from the reward
of his prayer. However, is it
permissible when there is a need to do
so? The answer is yes. Narrations in a
sunnah mention that the prophet would
turn his head in salah for any purpose.
whether it would would be because he
would be guarding the horizon in a time
of war or fear or because something
occurred and he needed to turn his head.
All the narration speaking about him
turning in salah. It's speaking about
his head not the chest. The chest cannot
turn from the direction of the
was narrated to have looked and turned
his head to see things while he is in
prayer. If there's a need for it, it
will not affect a person's prayer. Or
for instance, a person in salah is
looking at the im. They have to look at
the imam. They have to turn their head.
Correct. This is the sunnah. The sunnah
is a person in salah behind the im that
they look at the imam to see where he is
in the prayer and what position he is
going in.
This is something which is permissible.
However, this narration is speaking
about specifically in
or without need to do so. The only
direction that it is haram to look at in
salah is which direction?
Is up.
Is up. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam strictly prohibited raising the
vision above in salah. And he said, "A
person who raises his vision in salah is
in danger of Allah blinding him as a
response to this disrespect for prayer."
Okay. What is the next one? He mentions
and pecking the pecking of a of a
crow or a bird. What is this in
reference to? Which position of prayer?
and sujud, right? And most notably, this
is that a person does not come up
completely between the two sujud,
right?
Sitting between the two sagas is a
pillar of prayer. If a person does not
come up and find tranquility between the
two sagdas, their salah is invalid.
What is tranquility? for
that a person. They mentioned that the
bare minimum of tranquility in prayer is
that a person rise up to the position
and that their body
find complete stillness in that position
before they go on to the next position.
But often times a person is making
the sujud they they're making sujud they
come up halfway or almost all the way
and they go right back down. This is
prohibited and this will invalidate a
person's salah
because again sitting between the two
sagdas is what is a pillar of salah and
tranquility is a pillar of salah.
The next one he mentions
is that a person lay himself out like
the posture of a beast.
This is referring to what in in sujud,
you know, when cats or big big cats
or bears or these kinds of animals when
they lay on their belly, they usually
lay their whole forearm up to the elbow
on the ground. Right? This here touching
the ground with a person's forearm in
salah in sujud is prohibited in salah. A
person is to make sujud on his hands.
Right? The forearm should never be
touching the ground. Even if a person's
in a tight position in the prayer,
right? The hands are on the ground, but
the forearm is never touching the
ground. The next one he mentions is
that a person fall a camel does
when it goes to lay down. What position
is this speaking of
[Arabic recitation]
that mean? Does that mean that a person
when they go into sujud they should go
on their hands first or on their knees
first? What does the narration mean?
What do you think it means
hands?
So the scholars mention both but really
is that this narration is not referring
to hands or or knees. It's referring to
tranquility when falling into sujud
whether a person goes into their hands
or goes onto their knees first. This is
not what the narration is speaking of.
The narration is speaking of the
abruptness, the kind of falling, the
collapse that a person does when they go
in sujud a camel does. I don't know
if you have ever seen a camel when it
goes to lay down. It falls with with
with force. It's very it's very
clumsy when it falls forward and then
back. And so whether a person goes on
his knees or his hands, that's not what
the narration is speaking of. The
narration is speaking of a person
falling with that kind of with that kind
of clumsiness. Right? And often times
you can hear that if people are praying
if you're on on a level underneath
where people are praying above you, you
can often hear this mistake. When people
fall for sudoo
it's light it's thunder right
this is something which the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam prohibited
when a person falls for sujud they fall
with grace
they gracefully fall to sud right
whether the hands or the knees
the last one is clear and that is
that is that a person always pray in the
same place in the masid every prayer.
Camels are very particular creatures and
they are creatures of habit. when they
come into the me when when they come
into the masjid, when they go into
their, you know, wherever their place
is, their their place of living, they
always go to the same place, right? And
you can start to see the outline of
where it sits and it starts to dig into
the ground and leave an impression in
the ground cuz it's always there in the
same place. This is prohibited for a
person to always pray in the same place
in the masid every single day. Rather, a
person prays
wherever they happen to be at that time.
But to always pray in the same place,
this is incorrect. This is a mistake
people make in salah.
One of the reasons for this is that if
we always have the people praying in the
same exact place every day,
what starts to happen with that place,
it's we start to get ownership, start to
make people feel they have a right
to that. I'm always this is my place.
Nobody owns any part of the masid.
So a person cannot even say oh this is
my place I always pray here. No anyone
is rightful to any place in the masid at
any time whether they built the masid
with their hands or they just walked in
for the first time from the ends of the
earth.
Both have equal right to every place in
the masid that they happen to pray. And
this is a mistake that is often made
especially on silhouette Juma.
People come in they have their little
groups and they put out their mats and
nobody is allowed to come here and pray
in this place and then they wait for
their friends to come and fill up that
place. And so also another byproduct of
this is that people start to people
start to become you know have
these little groups in the masid that
in the masid. So now we got the Arabs
over here, we got the Indians over here,
we got the Pakistanisians over here and
and we don't really mix. We just, you
know, we come kind of together. We pray
real quick and then we retreat back to
our places and our respective groups
a prison yard. This is not how
salah is supposed to be in the masid. It
is supposed to be a congregational
effort and all places all the Muslims
have equal right and opportunity to any
of those places except two places.
Number one, the place where the imam
prays. That one doesn't change. And
number two, directly behind the imam.
This is reserved for who?
What's that? The
[Arabic recitation]
who are most memorized in the Quran.
And this is honestly a a problem that
happens and people should encourage
this to not happen. You see the the
huab or the people that if something
happened to the imam, they would be the
ones to take over the prayer or the ones
who you know are are the standins for
the imam or the assistance to the imam
or what have you. They're praying all
the way at the end at the far place and
then the people who have the least
you know memorization of the Quran
are praying right behind the imam. So if
anything happens to the im or the salah
we have no way to correct the prayer
and the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
that the most intelligent the most
mature the most knowledgeable they are
the ones to pray directly behind the im.
So this is usually I give this little
thing at the very beginning to try to
get you know people's minds active a
little bit before we take some questions
or as some of the brothers have
named it.
Who is there anybody that has any
questions for today? Yes. Hang on. Wait
for the microphone inshallah.
We have 11 minutes left. Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
access to the mask.
and then someone has to give you some
approval and you just said everybody
should have access to the mask. I know
it's some security measures but
I feel there's some profiling in
that. approve apply an approval for
what?
[Arabic recitation]
because of the codes over there.
masid is different than a person having
an equal right to pray any part of
the masid. So
if it were just a masid with no
valuables in it, with no reason for
there to be any doors on it or to be any
locks on it or something of that sort,
then sure. However, especially,
you know, for instance in our situation
here, we have a school, we have other
valuables in the masid, we have
potential for the masid to be abused,
etc. But for the time of prayer, when a
person comes into the masid, any place
of salah, they should have access to it.
But it doesn't mean that everyone gets a
key to the masid. We don't know who
people are. we have to protect the
masid. And there's more than just the
masid in the building, right?
Correct. Clear.
[Arabic recitation]
a key then.
you want to give access.
[Arabic recitation]
You said
prays here constantly with us
then they would and they're here usually
they would get a key code. But you
know what's the point of having a lock
if you give a key to everybody? We might
as well just take the lock off, right?
So, you know, there's a process
obviously for that. However, for the
message being open and people praying in
any position, that's that's something
that's open now.
[Arabic recitation]
just so that people watching online can
hear the question.
there is
residu
if there if a person comes into the
masid
[Arabic recitation]
listening to the d the talk or making a
sunnah
[Arabic recitation]
and both are permissible. However, what
is this break brings us back to an
age-old question amongst the scholars
which they've discussed in their books
and the fukah and Islamic jurists have
discussed and that is
seeking knowledge and
making
which one is more which one takes
precedence and the majority of the
scholarship of Islam are of the view
that seeking knowledge is the first
priority after obligations have been
fulfilled. Always.
Always. There is nothing that takes
priority over seeking knowledge
after obligations have been fulfilled.
If a person were to say for instance,
should I spend my time studying the
Quran or praying neil? We would say
studying the Quran. seeking knowledge,
listening to the scholarship of Islam,
etc. This is a priority after any
obligation.
Now,
yes, we have another question here with
brother.
[Arabic recitation]
Abu Ali's question. and then just a
quick second one. So the followup here
is as you mentioned let's say for
instance when you finish prayer right
after that you know when people are
doing their you know and whatnot
sometime I mean you will get up and then
try to give the talk in that case then
[Arabic recitation]
and then finish our you know and all
that stuff especially in the morning for
instance
[Arabic recitation]
and then just listen to the sheh who's
giving the talk because in that case
obviously
[Arabic recitation]
stuff
she for I mean then leaving your
[Arabic recitation]
sabah stuff you know or just listening
to the so that's that's one the second
one is just to follow up on that is
what is your take on sometimes I mean
you You may see a brother again it's not
anybody here just in general will be
praying and then you try to focus but
then you hear somebody maybe wave far to
your right he's you know is so loud
it just disturbs you misfocus type of
thing or you know he's next to you but
then really you're not focusing because
you hear all these things that he's
saying in his suj so if you can want to
just mention a little bit on that
[Arabic recitation]
to the same answer that was in the
previous question and that is making a
after the salah is it obligatory or
optional? It is an it is it is optional.
it will not affect the person's
prayer. Listening to knowledge is it
optional or obligatory? It could be
obligatory in in
but there is nothing to prevent a person
from joining both at the same time. So
we give the example we have the
salah and then we have a or a talk after
or after
the people that are present they can
continue with their while listening.
This is something which is permissible
and not only is it permissible but at
some points it may be highly advised
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam said in the narration of J that
if a person comes to the masid while the
im is giving
they should not sit until they make two
and
they are to make the two brief. So we
hear here here we have an instance where
a person is making salah while the
is going on and listening to the is an
obligation of J.
But there are instances when both can be
done together. If the student of
knowledge or sheh or scholar or what
have you were to begin to speak after
salah does the person who had just made
salah and had not finished his
have to stop making his because he's
speaking no they can continue their and
listen as for the second question
which is u regarding raising a person's
voice
in a silent part of prayer that it will
be disturbing to others. As a matter of
fact, some people recite
in their salah so loud. I've had it
where I'm in the row and I'm praying and
there's someone next to me reading surah
fat and I'm trying to read but because
his voice is so intrusive I'm saying
with him when he makes
right. This is something that not only
is impermissible but is incredibly
distracting and irritating. It's very
annoying. Again, the masid is a shared
space. We have to share it. Right? This
happens a lot as well when people come
into the masid and join the im. So the
im is in salah is reciting and someone
comes to Allahb.
We don't need that. We do not need that.
Right? a person is to enter into salah.
sometimes people will say it so loud
that I will stop reading because I think
somebody is correcting me, right? Or
when the imam goes to make or they make
a loud behind the im. None of this is of
the sunnah. All of this is prohibited if
it is distracting to those around you.
But an occasional raising of the voice
occasional
once in a blue moon
there was a this is something which is
permissible on occasion.
Let's say a person is well the
narration in inahkari once the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam came up from
and said
and one of the companions said
and after he said who said that and the
companion said I said that he said I saw
34 angels competing with each other who
of them is going to take it up to Allah
first. So he encouraged this dua and the
raising of the voice on very scarce
occasions is permissible in
the companion said the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam in leading us in
or would sometimes
let us hear
one or two verses of what he was
reciting. So he'd be reading for
instance
he would raise his voice this in a
natural way on occasion in a silent
prayer. That's a different story than a
person who is
whispering so loud that a person next
to them can hear and it will impede
their prayer. How loud should a person's
silent prayer be? This is really what
the question gets down to when we say
silent prayer.
So it's an an inaudible prayer. It's
it's
etc.
How loud should the person be? What is
the minimum
loudness volume and what is the maximum
volume in that situation? mentions
in his book
that under normal circumstances
a person in a quiet environment should
be able to hear himself.
That is the maximum and minimum volume
that the fukah have given for recitation
and silent prayers. So, as I'm reading
under normal environment, meaning if a
person is praying next to a diesel truck
or or or a a compressor, right, or some
some kind of loud thing, they wouldn't
hear themselves. But under normal quiet
conditions, environment, they would
be able to hear their own whisper. This
is how loud a person should be in silent
prayer.
Nothing below that is permissible.
If a person only uses his mouth, moves
his mouth but cannot hear himself in a
normal environment, that prayer would
not be valid.
There's another thing which is reciting
in a person's mind without moving the
mouth.
This is an invalid prayer according to
the consensus of all of the in the for
and sometimes you'll see this a person
instead of reading in fata
they will just be that they're
they're not moving their lips they're
not moving their mouth
and they will say I'm reading in my
heart or I'm reading in myself this is
invalid accord according to the
consensus of the scholars. Why? Because
it's not recitation. We're commanded to
recite.
We're commanded to say certain things in
prayer. If a person's mouth does not
move and there is no sound whatever,
this is not recitation according to the
Arabic language.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
Muslim
and
[Silence]
so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said in a
narration in Muslim, I am with my
servant when he remembers me, when he
makes mention of me and his lips. lips
move with my mention.
So this means that a person has to move
his lips and his tongue and there has to
be some
sound otherwise it is not considered to
be recitation. Now if there's any
more questions otherwise we have gone
past our time inshallah. Anyone else?
one question
long question
at your own risk inshallah.
[Arabic recitation]
know the person in their life
want to up to oneird of what they own if
it has to do with the earns errors
and I know one/ird is probably too high.
We we've heard that before and we know
that. So the question is number one if
somebody does not follow this and really
goes beyond the one-third or spends more
amongst some of the earths and not all
of them
[Arabic recitation]
punishment or the consideration that's
the question. Number two, is there a
scenario where perhaps you have six,
seven children, one of them is totally
in need.
Your income level comes on a like
payment monthly basis.
[Arabic recitation]
which would take all your income after
your expenses. And this looks like
you're spending all your money and and
you're not considering the others. Is
this condition of need
negates that or the fault the the
inheritance condition does not fall into
that
tell you for the first question
inheritance
is when a person dies that is the
specific time and ruling of inheritance.
So what does this mean? Let's say a
person is not deathly ill. They're not
on their deathbed
and they are not expecting to die.
Are they is it permissible for them to
give of their money whatever they want?
The answer is yes. It's permissible.
Hypothetically, it's permissible if I
had a fortune of whatever and I'm
healthy and in good state of mind to
give it all to charity. that's
permissible for me because that's my
wealth. There would be other issues that
might come up. Maybe I have obligations
that I have to tend to maybe that's a
different story. However, is that
impermissible for me? The answer is no.
Because that is not inheritance. That is
still my my money. When is it
impermissible?
In two situations. Number one, the
person's intention behind doing that is
to stunt the inheritance of their heirs.
This is haram. And this is what is
referred to as a
which is doing something haram with an
outward image of halal and that is haram
and a major sin. The second time is if a
person is ill and expecting to die. So
let's say a person gets some kind of
cancer diagnosis and or some kind of
diagnosis that you have a month a year
to live and so now they have their
children and they start thinking well if
I wait till I die then
it has to be divided this way but I like
this kid more than this one or I want to
give this one more than this one. So
they give it in the form of a gift, but
it's when they're expecting to die. This
is a major sin in Islam and it is the
same ruling as the one before it.
Even if it is just a gift, if I give a
child a gift, it is haram in Islam to
give a gift to one child and not give it
to the others even if they are male or
female. So if I give a gift to my son
then I need to give an equal gift to my
daughter. I have to the prophet said
inki
he was
one of the companions brought his
sonbashir
and he said I want you to be testify oh
messenger of Allah and bear witness to
me giving this servant to my son in he
said does he have siblings he said Yes,
he said I will not bear witness to
oppression.
Why? Because he is not going to give a
servant as well to the rest of his
children. So if it is just a gift when a
person's not dying then they have to
give equal gifts to their children that
doesn't follow the rulings of where a
boy or a male receives two portions and
a female one.
or if the person is trying to short
circuit or take a trying to interfere
with the inheritance of his heirs, this
is haram. Or if a person is on his
deathbed or expecting to die and so they
start to give gifts out out of with the
intention of that being from their
inheritance in order to divide their
inheritance in a way which is haram.
This is impermissible. All three of
these are impermissible.
what about us as the people who are
there for the inheritance? Let's say a
person is passing away. They write a
will or they give an inheritance and
they give to one more than another or
they choose to
give from that onethird and they go
more than a third. It is haram to obey
that will. Why? Because a lot of times
we misunderstand the essence of the
ruling of inheritance. What is the
essence? The essence is inheritance does
not belong to me.
It is no longer mine once I pass away or
expect to die. It is no longer my money.
I earned it. Yeah, I earned it. Allah
gave it to me. But when a person dies,
it no longer belongs to them. And they
cannot choose how that is distributed.
anything beyond a third and that
one-third
cannot go to any of his natural heirs.
The prophet says in
so that third is to give to anyone
except for his heirs. If it is to his
heirs, impermissible.
Now
this is regarding a person's inheritance
and how it should be divided. This is
something that is an obligation upon a
person. If they do not make sure that
this happens upon their death, they will
be held accountable. And what will they
be held accountable for? For stealing.
Why? What do you mean stealing? Yes,
stealing. because that is not their
money.
All right? So if I try to
move this money around after my death
in a way that is not commanded by Allah,
I am now moving around money that
doesn't belong to me. That is the ruling
in Islam for someone who does that
with regards to inheritance. And then
it's it's an extremely delicate and very
very grave issue in Islam. And so for us
here in America for instance, we could,
you know, person could hypothetically
give all of their money to their pet if
they want to. They could give it to
their pet lizard if they want to, right?
Because we live in an insane place, an
insane time. And you know that's
that's what it's to live in the
circus that we live in. But what is the
obligation upon a Muslim who has wealth
that will be inherited
with regards to his will and testament?
He is to write a willing testament that
is to outline exactly what would
naturally be given in the Quran
and the distribution that's mentioned in
the two verses of and the final verse of
[Arabic recitation]
you have more kids
need
others, you know, don't need it and one
needs or two needs.
[Arabic recitation]
financial support. All right. That was
one of the question. Yeah. I mean, if I
have a number of children and one of
them is in need of zak and they're
grown, can I give them zak? Yes, you can
give them from the zakat. Why? because
it's not obligatory for you to support
them because they're grown. Now, zaka is
permissible to a person who is of age
who a person who is it's permissible to
a family member even a child as long as
the person does not
does not try to hit two birds with
one stone. We know that.
So for instance person has a child and
they are obliged to spend their money
on this child support this child or
their wife. They say well I have to give
zakat too. So I'll I'll hit two birds
with one stone. I'll give my zakat to my
dependence. I gave my zaky and I right
this is the impermissible way of giving
zak
she is not obliged to support her
husband in this instance. So her zakat
to her needy husband if he if he is one
of those eight then it is permissible
and the same thing if the children are
grown for instance say the children are
no longer my dependent right
and they are poor and they are eligible
for zaka is it permissible for me to
give my zakat to them yes it's
permissible to give zakat to your
children to your uncles to your
family members as long as you are not
otherwise obliged to support them.
Right? The same thing goes with the
will. Let's say a person now has a
child that he supports and he's
supporting them from his wealth.
that would upon his death turn into
their inheritance. As long as he is not
on his deathbed or trying to give away
his heir's
inheritance by doing that, it's
permissible because it's still his
money. He can give it to whoever he
wants. But upon a diagnosis or a
deathbed or what have you, an
expectation of death, now it becomes
impermissible to interfere with anything
more than one-third. So if you have
five children and you support one of
them who is genuinely in need of your
support and you don't support the other
four, is that permissible? Yes. That's
not a gift. That's support. That's
different. That's a But if you're giving
a gift, even if they're wealthy or poor,
you have to give equally
[Silence]
with